oh hi welcome to game life I'm today's
show you'll learn how Microsoft might be
planning to sell the xbox 360 for just
$99 how Nintendo might be selling you
new super mario brothers to as it
download and how you and your friends
could be exploring Skyrim altogether
starting next year last week the website
the verge reported that Microsoft is
considering selling the xbox 360 like it
was a cell phone selling the box for
ninety nine dollars and then tying users
into a fifteen dollar a month
subscription fee the subscription fee
might include Xbox Live and other types
of video content like television and
streaming video that have arrived on
xbox live as of late while Microsoft
hasn't officially confirmed these rumors
the verge said that it could start
selling the low-cost Xbox through its
Microsoft stores very soon I think this
is a great idea if it works for cell
phones it can work for video game
systems as Xbox Live gets more and more
streaming video content paying 15 bucks
a month for a subscription makes a lot
more sense Nintendo has said that it is
going to boldly leap feet first into the
recent past and begin to offer its major
video games as downloads beginning in
August with new super mario brothers to
on the Nintendo 3ds you will have the
option of downloading or buying the game
on a cartridge in the store and Nintendo
has said that on day one when it
releases its new Wii U console later
this year you will also be able to
either download or buy its games on a
disk
finally fans of the Elder Scrolls games
are about to lose what little shred of
social life they had left after Skyrim
zenimax media has announced in the June
issue of game informer magazine that
elder scrolls online a massively
multiplayer online version of the
popular role-playing game series is
coming in 2013 you'll be able to explore
the entire land of Tamriel with your
friends cooperative solo player versus
player everywhere from elsewhere to
Skyrim we here at game wife would like
to implore you if you haven't seen your
family in a little while you you may
want to just spend some time with them
play with your dog you know just just to
enjoy the real world a little bit
because you really don't have much of
that left one elder scrolls releases in
2013 that's it for this week we will see
you next time and remember if you
haven't gotten your tickets for Penny
Arcade Expo in seattle yet haha they're
sold out
you